als rocker bei den hells angels da war
er gefürchtet doch jetzt ist sah man wie
der mann hinter mir dieser gefürchtete
käfigkämpfer selbst ein gejagter
denn seine ehemaligen rocker brüder die
erklärten ihn für vogelfrei und jetzt
fielen schüsse unsere kollegen george an
polos alex tala stunde die von der osten
berichten
versuchten mordanschlag mitten im herzen
kölns rahm zwanzigster oktober 1 uhr 30
hells angels rocker und boxer sah man b
ist auf dem weg nach hause nur noch
wenige meter von seiner haustür entfernt
plötzlich peitschen schüsse durch die
luft
der ehemalige hells angels rocker smb
wurde opfer eines versuchten
mordanschlag
er ging hier die straße entlang als
plötzlich von einem schützen von der
gegenüber liegenden straßenseite
mindestens drei schüsse fielen da man
wie stinkt hinter einem haltenden pkw
kommt so dem kugelhagel die schüsse
verfehlten knapp eine kugel durchschlug
die hinteren seitenscheiben eines
geparkten pkws einschusslöcher sind auch
sichtbar eine hausfassade und einer
gläsernen
eingangstür der schütze unbekannt er
soll zu fuß vom tatort geflüchtet sein
möglicherweise filmt eine
überwachungskamera in der nähe des
tatorts die flucht die ermittler der
mordkommission haben jetzt sämtliches
videomaterial aus überwachungskameras
aus der umgebung gesichert die
auswertung dauern an doch was ist der
hintergrund des mordanschlags auf sah
man b rückblick die rocker sah man ist
jahrelang die rechte hand von fatih k
auch boxer und chef der hells angels in
köln ehrenfeld dem sogenannten charter
oder vier jahre lang arbeiten sie hand
in hand sah man soll vatis
geldeintreiber und wichtigster
gefolgsmann bei illegalen geschäften
sein doch dann kommt es zum bruch der
rocker brüder sah man fühlt sich von
seinem chef partie ausgenutzt wirft dem
rocker boss öffentlich vor er regiere
das starterfeld diktatorisch in seiner
autorität angegriffen soll fatih einen
15 köpfigen schlägertrupp auf seine
ehemalige rechte hand im charter-
gehetzt haben sah man entkommt dem
angriff und veröffentlicht daraufhin ein
20 minütiges instagram video in dem er
fatih droht beleidigt und vorführt
ich kenne dich ich war über zehn jahre
neben der tag und nacht ich habe so viel
über dich material ich habe so viel
fundiert wenn ich einmal überdenken
würde würdest du nie wieder aus diesem
zelle rauskommen ja club habe ich
geliebt denn du hast mich brunnen
ehrenhaft mit lügen daraus geht etwas
angst in der wichtigen schauspiel
köln ist kurz vor einer revolution
du bist ein mit pater nunmehr maskierter
mann löschte sein herz video zwar
bereits kurze zeit nach der
veröffentlichung
hochrangige hells angels mitglieder
sollen ihnen nach bild informationen
dazu gedrängt haben doch cottbus fathi
vergisst nicht er schmeißt den in
ungnade gefallenen sah man raus
outstanding wer aus einem rockerclub mit
dem status auto im bett standing für zu
lebenden zielscheiben jeder rocker darf
das ex-mitglied beschimpfen verprügelt
sogar töten für sah man bedeutet dass
akute lebensgefahr erst vogelfrei
bereits vor dem versuchten mordanschlag
warnten erfahrene ermittler rocker
milieu sah man vor partys rache achtung
verhandlung liegt die aufgezeichnete
gefährderansprache vor
hast ja gesehen schritt mit 15 mal im
griff vor meiner haustür egal wo sie
sind da
werden sie sich
schaffen die staatsanwaltschaft köln
sucht jetzt den schützen vom 23 oktober
und ermittelt wegen versuchten mordes an
sah man b offiziell heißt es gegen
unbekannt die fahndung läuft sah man b
ist inzwischen untergetaucht
und über diese rocker rache wollen wir
weiter sprechen wie christian maxdorf
der bei uns ist professor für
kriminalistik selbst viele jahre kripo
ermittler schon guten abend und wir
haben es gehört sah man bei wurde also
als vogelfrei erklärt was bedeutet dass
und vor allem wie gefährlich ist das und
im mittelalter hat man menschen als
vogelfrei bezeichnet wenn sie
ausgestoßen worden sind aus der
gemeinschaft ähnlich wie hier der rocker
aus seiner gemeinschaft der
gleichgesinnten und man konnte dann mit
diesen menschen machen was man wollte
man konnte sie verletzen und töten und
genau das bedeutet auch diese ausdruck
für den ausgestoßenen rocker hier es
wird sogar erwartet dass mitglieder dass
der rocker gemeinschaft ihnen wenn sie
ihn antreffen verletzen oder töten und
sie gehen nach ihren eigenen gesetzen
vorgesetzte in anführungsstrichen sie
gehen danach vor und werden das sogar
belohnen dann wenn es erfolgreich sein
sollte ist abgesagt ein wort aus dem
mittelalter und auch diese regeln und
der umgang der mit der klingt ja sehr
mittelalterlich ja das ist sehr schade
hier gibt es natürlich immer wieder
macht machtdemonstration und wenn jemand
die macht spieler wie es ja hier
offensichtlich passiert ist wenn jemand
die unangefochtene position eines
preises eines präsidenten eines
rockerclubs hier so angreift dann ist er
natürlich auch die zielscheibe von allen
möglichen maßnahmen bis hin zur tötung
was uns fasziniert hat da gab es diese
ansprache also einen polizisten der das
spätere
anschlagsopfer anspricht und sagt pass
auf die droht da das und das wie oft
konnte was vor und welche beamten führen
solche gespräche durch ja wir kennen auf
der einen seite die gefährderansprache
da richtet man sich an den ihnen von dem
die gefahr geht es gibt aber genauso gut
die ansprachen die sich an gefährdete
person richten wie hier diesen rocker
den ausgestoßenen rocker eben und da
gibt man verhaltenshinweise in einigen
fällen gibt und auch hilfsangebote es
kommt ganz darauf an in welcher form
sich da jetzt jemand die welcher form
man zum opfer geworden ist das machen
allerdings keine ganz normalen
polizisten das sind dann szenekundige
spezialisierte operative kräfte die ganz
besonders die rockerszene eben kennen
und sich dort auch etabliert haben also
dass ansprechpartner eben auch bekannt
sind dafür sie aus ihrer eigenen
erfahrung fragen bringt das was
ich habe in der vergangenheit immer
wieder gestaunt das ist tatsächlich
meine eigene erfahrung dass diese
beamten und nahmen die dort als zähne
unterwegs sind und die man kennt und die
also wirklich etabliert sind dort dass
die in gutes standing haben um meine
rocker sprache zu bleiben und dass man
auf die hört also dass man mit denen
spricht und dass die teilweise sogar als
einzige polizeiliche ansprechpartner
überhaupt akzeptiert werden also
insofern würde ich sagen ganz allgemein
bringt das etwas ja mit sicherheit in
diesem konkreten fall hier ist die
gefährderansprache die ansprache des
gefährdeten müssen wir sagen ja insofern
obsolet als dass derjenige schon weiß
dass er sich in lebensgefahr befindet
und insofern kann man ihm eigentlich
noch verhaltenshinweise geben aber man
kann eben nicht mehr informieren darüber
dass ein gefährt das weiß er selber
interessant war auch so der kumpelhafte
ton finde ich wie man miteinander
gesprochen hat nicht unbedingt so wie
man es jetzt erwartet wenn man mit einem
polizisten spricht was uns auch noch
fasziniert hat an diesem fall ist dass
die hauptperson der mann dahinter mir
sah man b heißt dann haben wir von einem
vater gehört wo sind all die deutschen
rocker mit dem blonden locker dieses
klischee wo sind die alle hin gibt es
nicht mehr also wenn wir von ganz ganz
früher sprechen dann waren rockerclubs
er eine mono ethnische vereinigung ja er
auch in der rechten ecke anzusiedeln als
in anderen politischen bereichen wenn
überhaupt von politik gesprochen werden
kann dann gab es vor zehn jahren ein
ganzes am tisch umbruch zunächst bei den
bandidos wir erinnern uns an kg der erst
chef der bandidos wurde dann rüber ging
zu den hells angels dort eine leitende
funktion hatte und mit diesem dammbruch
wurden immer mehr menschen mit
migrationshintergrund diese klubs
aufgenommen heute sind die klubs
dominiert von menschen die entsprechend
multi ethnische aufgestellt sind und das
hat natürlich den hintergrund dass sich
hier zwei bereiche vor einigen mit einem
gemeinsamen ziel wir haben die
organisierte kriminalität und wir haben
die rockerkriminalität alles zusammen
ist ein großer schmelztiegel und es geht
immer um geld und macht unter spielen
hier keine rolle düstere aussichten von
professor matzdorf danke dass sie heute
bei uns waren sehr gerne und wir haben
es gehört die polizei ermittelt in
diesem fall mittlerweile wegen
versuchten mordes der oder die täter die
wurden aber bislang nicht identifiziert
und die ermittler fragen wer hat in der
nacht des 22
auf den 23 oktober beobachtungen in der
kölner altstadt gemacht hinweise an die
staatsanwaltschaft köln unter 0221